Speaker 1: I'm Jesse Moore, sitting
in for David while he is on vacation.
Hey, listen, if you've been enjoying the the look
of my stupid face and the sound of my dumb voice,
I would encourage you to click the links
on the top of the description there
and check out where you can find me on social
media and on YouTube. You know, one of the the the
major drawbacks of the political divide that has
largely been created by Donald Trump and his camp
is the fact that truth is no longer true. Science
is no longer respected. That kind of has been
the case with the Republican Party for a long
time, but it has really hit a fever pitch under
Donald Trump and this new fascistic version of the
Republican Party. And part of that is obviously
vaccine hesitancy, which is borne out of a
contempt for expertize and a contempt for science.
They mock the educated. They they
are they are pleased as punch to be
the poorly educated. Remember when Donald
Trump said that on the campaign trail?
I love we love the poorly educated.
Speaker 2: We won the evangelicals.
We won with young, we won with old, we
won with highly educated. We won with
poorly educated. I love the poorly educated.
Speaker 1: And one of the the downfalls of
America being such a touchstone culturally
across the globe is the fact that our idiots
are idiots, are contagious. And they it leads
to vaccine hesitancy and anti science views,
even outside of the borders of the United States.
Enter the story from Reuters, which is tragic
and scary, suspected sailin switch sparked
vaccine stir in Germany. Authorities in
northern Germany appealed to thousands of people
on Tuesday to get another shot of covid-19 vaccine
after a police investigation found that a
Red Cross nurse may have injected them with a
saline solution. In place of a covid vaccine.
Adding to the hysteria and the fear here is that
this nurse is suspected of injecting salt solution
into people's arms instead of genuine doses at
a vaccine center in Friesland, a rural district
near the North Sea coast in the early spring. And
the early spring is the element of this. That is
really a bummer, because that was when the elderly
en masse were getting vaccinated to go back and
start living their lives with far less trepidation
and worry that they might catch the disease and be
hospitalized or die. Quote, I'm totally shocked by
this episode, end quote. Svend Ambrosi, a local
councilor, said on Facebook as local authorities
issued the call to around 8600 residents who
may have been affected. While saline solution
is harmless. Most people who got vaccinated in
Germany in March and April when the suspected
switch took place, are elderly people at high risk
of catching the potentially fatal viral disease.
The motive of the nurse, who was not
named was not clear. But she had aired
skeptical views about vaccines and social media
posts. Police investigators said it was not
immediately clear whether the suspect had been
arrested or charged in the case, which, according
to broadcaster NDR, has been handed to a special
unit that investigates politically motivated
crimes. That is sad. That health care
that a a a a vaccine with proven efficacy.
Has been turned into some kind of political
football among conspiracy theorists and
chaos stirrers, as it is in the case
of the American political system.
This isn't a political issue, this is a
global health crisis, the likes of which
we haven't seen for 100 years. And because of
idiots who want to maintain political power.
Culture warriors. Things like this are happening,
this could be laid directly at the feet of the
Republican Party, even though it's for him.